hey what is up guys mpbhd here and
welcome back to
prime picks yes we've officially named
the series so shout out to everyone who
uh suggested names and for those who
agreed with that one and in this episode
we're taking a look at the absolute
best-selling headphones on all of amazon
so the number one most popular stuff in
the uh personal audio department and
there's a couple different categories
for headphones as you probably already
know there are earbuds there are on-ear
headphones and there are wireless
headphones so we've got the prime picks
here for all of those now i've talked
about headphones before you might have
already heard me talk about audio
technica's athm50s i've reviewed a
couple pairs of beats i've talked about
my favorite bose headphones some
jaybirds but those were all well over
100 bucks but these number one selling
headphones all have something in common
which is that they're all cheap they're
all
less than 100 bucks they're all less
than 50 bucks they're all very
inexpensive so at the time of this
recording the number one earbuds on all
of amazon are these panasonic ergo fit
earbuds nine bucks 50 000 reviews four
stars
pretty basic the number one over ear
headphones are these mpow
zero five nine hi-fi stereo headphones
35 bucks 15 000 reviews at four and a
half stars and the number one wireless
headphones on amazon are what do you
know also made by mpow the mpow flame
bluetooth headphones 20 bucks 8 000
reviews at again four and a half stars
now i have my thoughts and feelings
about one company kind of dominating the
best sellers list of all of accessories
on amazon including headphones but
that's a whole other video but basically
i thought a lot about why people buy
these why these have ended up at the top
of amazon why they're the best sellers
and what it comes down to is it's a lot
of expectations
positioning and a little bit of luck but
i'll go over all that at the end
basically the reasons people just buy
super cheap headphones and this
especially applies to earbuds is people
buying headphones at this price don't
really care about a whole lot basically
what it comes down to is people buying
super cheap headphones around these
prices really only care about a couple
of things what they do care about is
number one how functional and convenient
they are you know they they plug in
they're easy to use
number two how comfortable they are
pretty straightforward you can wear them
for a long time and not feel any pain
number three how durable they are i
don't want them to break again i just
want them to last as long as possible
with my use and not fall apart early
we've all seen cable fraying and plastic
cracking and then last but not least is
how good they sound notice this is kind
of low on the list and in all honesty by
the time you replace something that
broke most people are just happy it
works and sound quality is not the top
priority here and honestly this priority
list i think explains the existence of
what i think may be the most popular
pair of headphones in the world by
volume it's a pair of headphones that
you probably haven't actually bought
with your own money or at least
consciously done it it's earpods earpods
are super functional and super
convenient i mean they come in the box
with your phone they're built and
designed for the iphone they're super
lightweight so they're comfortable for a
surprising amount of people and then
durability and sound are just barely
average they're good enough but they're
just so convenient but what if your ear
pods break what if what if you come up
you know that the cable starts to fray
something breaks about them you don't
feel like contributing maybe to apple's
trillion dollars so you head over to
amazon and you find the most popular
headphones and you just end up with
these so okay the panasonic ergofit
headphones functional and convenient yes
nine bucks on amazon next day shipping
this is definitely convenient they plug
right in with a 90 degree jack assuming
assuming you have a headphone jack i
forgot to mention but assuming you have
a headphone jack these are really
convenient they plug right in they are
pretty comfortable mostly because they
are super lightweight so they're easy to
forget about in your ear and they don't
make a great seal or anything but
there's multiple size rubber tips in the
box so you can adjust that durability i
think is my biggest concern this does
not look like a cable that would survive
very much stress at all it's kind of
thin and wiry one of those that would
like peel apart after a while
but it's fine for now but then how do
they sound
[Music]
make
sounds it's funny it's actually harder i
think for me to evaluate uh these than
really really good quality headphones
because i'm used to hearing a certain
range of things
but
they work that's really what matters
they sound fine you're not missing any
frequencies they're not super bass heavy
or super tinny or anything like that
so it's all right all right onto these
mpow over-ear headphones they come in a
bunch of colors i picked red and black
naturally
i think from some angles they kind of
resemble beats like some old beats
studios or even the solos from a couple
years ago because of the shape of the
plastic and these ear cups
but these are 35 bucks so i won't
complain and they are wireless bluetooth
headphones with up to a 20 hour quoted
battery life same as my bose qc35 and
they're rechargeable via micro usb also
the same as the bose so are they
functional and convenient yeah i mean it
was about as much as headphones like
this can be they do have
some midi controls on the side so if
you're into that you can play pause you
can accept and reject calls volume up
and down and they fold up for travel so
i feel like you can bring these just
about anywhere any other pair of over
ear headphones will go and they are
actually pretty comfortable they have
soft ear cups that fully surround your
ear the top band also has a cushion
plenty of headphones are way less
comfortable than this durability these
might be about as durable as beets i
mean they use plastics in a lot of the
same places there's thin metal at the
joints i i don't expect you to be able
to beat these up or toss them around but
if you do take care of them they'll be
fine they'll just get really
fingerprinty they're not sweat proof
like the earbuds though so this is not a
workout pair of headphones and then of
course how do they sound
[Music]
[Applause]
this weird hiss
they have this weird hiss when
well when they're connected and then
as soon as i hit pause
when the music stops there's like a
for like a second and then it stops and
then i play i press play again and it
comes back and the sound plays but
there's this hiss
i think it kind of sounds like i'm
listening through like a bed sheet like
if i if i had a
like a pillow sheet up to my ear between
that kind of that's what it sounds like
i don't know they're just like slightly
muffled like the frequency response
probably looks kind of like this they're
not super bass heavy which i actually
like i think a lot of headphones that
just over exaggerate the bass are easy
for me to rip on because they're clearly
doing it wrong but these uh
they sound alright the isolation is
pretty good too i'll give them that you
put them on your ears they're not noise
canceling but because they surround your
ear the passive noise isolation is
pretty good and then the number one of
all wireless headphones on amazon is
these 20 earbuds by mpow these these are
definitely on a sporty slant so they're
sweat proof they have this cable this
flat cable a seven to nine hour battery
life claimed and they also kind of
resemble some sporty beats i've seen
they are functional and convenient for
people looking for like wireless earbuds
that are way cheaper than airpods for
example these have almost all the same
functionality obviously no w1 chips so
they don't have quite the same deep
integration as airpods that everyone
loves but bluetooth pairing is still
pretty easy at this point you can leave
them loose kind of just like hanging the
cable back here or you can do the wire
clamp to fit them on the back your neck
like the jaybirds
and uh that's how they look so for
comfort there's still all the different
sizes of rubber tips but if you want to
change that you of course have them in
the box and then the over ear arch that
kind of hooks over is more universal
than the wing tip that tries to go up
into your ear i think this is going to
fit more people's ears durability of
these is actually probably the best of
the bunch which is pretty good for 20
bucks ipx7 water resistance a decent
quality flat red and black cable rubber
and plastic mostly everywhere else and
they come with this case that you can
zip them up in that you can throw them
around in
now sound
[Music]
i would characterize these as functional
they're definitely a little heavier with
the base than the other two which is
interesting for earbuds but i think
again this this all falls into a kind of
a nice sporty package generally i mean
audiophiles aren't buying these but when
you consider again that these are 20
bucks maybe a little more shipped that's
uh cheaper than earpods and you're
getting a lot more for that price so
what if i what have we learned here
today honestly despite the length of the
video there's not really all that much
to say about cheap headphones you kind
of just hope they work they do what
they're supposed to do they're
advertised maybe one or two extra little
features like being sweatproof or having
a little thing that goes over your ear
to keep them on your ear longer that
kind of stuff is nice but at the end of
the day if they work well
that's pretty much good enough for nine
bucks that's why these are prime picks
the question of how do they get to the
top of amazon we could talk about that
all day but essentially what it comes
down to is these are about as good as
the competition they're around the same
price they're a bit on the low side and
then basically they're just
rise to the top by whatever means
necessary and stay there because they're
good enough my biggest thumbs up from
the number ones that we tested i think
would be these mpow the flame the
earbuds i think they're the most
complete and they represent like a
package you could actually recommend for
20 bucks sweat resistant again decent
quality cable durability is probably the
biggest strength of these compared to
what else is on this table but i could
also see myself recommending these for
like kids i mean if they're like maybe
they get their eye on some more
expensive fancy headphones in best buy
these kind of have the same look to them
and do almost the same job i don't know
i mean if they're asking for beats then
they probably already know they want
beats but if they're asking for nice red
and black headphones then
these are fine but that is it that's it
for prime picks episode two of the
number one best headphones on amazon i
have a question for you if you had to
live with one of these headphones for
life
on this table which one would you pick
and why
either way let me know what other
categories you'd like to see in the
prime picks series until the next one
thank you for watching talk to you guys
later
peace